so which one's your favorite pink jelly
peanut butter jelly what's your other
favorite cool I love having boy sugar
sugar
[Music]
everything has sugar I'm Hannah and the
world's up case mom and my family has a
sugar problem now I feel like it's my
fault because I'm a busy working mom and
I let a lot of things slide and I kind
of say yes a little bit too much and so
now my kids are expecting treats all the
time and I feel like their behaviors
suffering as a result they're not
getting good sleep and they're throwing
a lot of tantrums lately now I'm not a
nutritionist but I think we can all
agree the too much sugar is not good for
you so I want to try something for one
whole week I'm gonna cut out all added
sugar from my family's diets now I'm not
saying we're gonna last a whole week not
saying we're gonna be okay with it and
we might end up eating each other at the
end but I'm gonna stay positive and see
what happens so wishes luck
so some ground rules for the week
because sugar is kind of a broad term
the sugar that we were cutting out was
added processed sugar
we weren't cutting out fruit we're not
cutting out fruit juice but anything
that has sugar added to it or any
processed sugar at all was off the table
so I went specially grocery shopping at
the beginning of the week for this
experiment
[Music]
so I am pretty shaken up over how much
stuff actually has sugar in it I felt
completely lost in that grocery store
and I was like checking every label and
I'd get through like 90% of the
ingredients and then boom at the bottom
sugar I was very surprised to see just
how much has sugar in it that I've
thrown in my cart and not even thought
about like tomato sauce and I was
looking at the different brands I
actually found one that didn't have
sugar in it and so had I just taken the
time before to check I wouldn't be
purchasing tomato sauce with sugar all
this time he's upset because he really
wanted cake cereal and we're doing
cottage cheese and fruit okay so I
totally forgot we have catered lunch
today No
I don't know what on this no this is my
plate it looks like don't work a
rabbit's Lee stop plate no because she
hates me
by literally I am like not looking
forward to it
[Music]
like wet pail getting home really dawned
on me that I'm gonna be doing a lot of
cooking this week you want dinner you
wanna eat the broccoli I'm making no yes
tonight we're gonna have some roasted
broccoli and some chicken and tri-tip
for the boys
pretty good Jackson he's got some
broccoli tried to chicken inside out PJ
shirt it is 8 p.m. we're currently
eating so in addition to changing my
shopping habits I had to change my whole
wind down evening me time relaxation
habits I get home from work we do dinner
get the kids in bed and then that's my
time to shine and I park my butt right
here on this couch grab kind of ice
cream turn on by true crime shows and I
just slug out now I try to deny this to
my kids I try to pretend like it doesn't
happen but they know I'm not eating
sugar
[Music]
no of kids are asleep and this is
typically the time that I would raid the
freezer and get some ice cream or get
some candy but I'm not gonna do that my
body is like come on it's time but now
so I'm gonna eat some kale snacks that
my mom gave me so I made this oatmeal
this morning it took forever and I'm
gonna throw some blackberries on it and
that's breakfast I ended up having to
make oatmeal from scratch because a lot
of the packaged oatmeal and the instant
oatmeal has sugar in it if its flavored
oatmeal is really good oh my god you
like it yeah they were super excited
about the oatmeal I made and we're like
oh it's actually good not some dank
oatmeal I should say take zinc is done
cuz I said it DANC is officially over no
one can say that anymore
I'm sorry to the youth so very quickly I
realized that at work I needed to bring
all of my own food because I work at
tasty it's the most epic Food Channel
ever and there's always the most
delicious food just coming out of that
kitchen 24/7 it's just too tempting with
all the snacks and all the catered
lunches and all this delicious food
that's always there Nick and I are
having our healthy lunches am I not that
kind of I wanted her
I didn't bring a piece of fruit I should
have brought like a piece of fruit with
me and I ended up starting to live
vicariously through my co-workers can
you just taste it and tell me how it
tastes
yeah
am I missing out there's something
really satisfying about watching someone
else enjoy food I'd be like all up in
their mouth like let me see it's
chocolate and white chocolate and
shortbread so good all right another
morning another breakfast grind and
lunch grind what do you want
doctors requested oatmeal and Wyatt has
requested a quesadilla this morning so
I'm making it cuz it doesn't have any
sugar but it's really tough when they
each asked for something different and I
have to make two breakfasts I'm actually
feeling okay today my face it's a little
less puffy usually it's really puffy
when I wake up and I think that's
partially due to the excessive amount
ice cream I eat at night for me I have a
really big sweet tooth and I realized
throughout this week how much I rely on
sugar for energy throughout the day I am
the first one home this evening so I'm
going to go ahead and start making
dinner today was pretty difficult but I
feel like it's getting easier although I
do have a crazy work week this week and
I have noticed that me craving sugar has
kind of clouded my ability to work a
little cuz I'm thinking about it a lot
more I'm kind of craving it but I have a
great dinner plan tonight making a
falafel feast with this flatbread and
hummus and garlic spread and to play and
to C key and olives and it's gonna be
delicious and very happy with this
dinner the kids already ate I do feed
them I promise
towards the end of the week I really
thought we had jumped over a hurdle like
we were on our way and doing great but
then I made the mistake of deviating
from my usual special oatmeal and I
decided to make pancakes and I used this
pancake mix that's you know full of
wheat flour and protein and no added
sugar but then when I served them I
realized I had nothing to put on top of
them and that did not go over well he's
great because it won't
syrup on his pancakes I'm sorry
sweetheart so Matt agreed to participate
in this experiment as well which I was
really excited about because we're all
doing it as a family obviously we eat
breakfast and dinner together but I
wanted him to suffer like I was
suffering but I don't know if I quite
trust that he followed through every day
when he was gone at work how'd you do
today no added sugar had a veggie
burrito really in his defense I didn't
make it easy for him do our ice cream
should we cheat no it's been like five
days let's keep going
we have Magnum bars in the freezer why
are you saying this and just so you guys
know that I haven't edited this to make
myself look completely guilt free and
like I did this experiment perfectly I
have a confession I messed up she
cheated I messed up I didn't mean to it
was totally by accident I had a
co-worker who was like tasting all these
things and she's like can you taste this
and tell me if it's spicy and I'm like
oh I love spicy food I put it in my
mouth and the second I did I was like oh
I could taste the sugar on it I just my
hands just grab food if it's offered and
they just move right to my mouth my
hands have a mind of their own
okay day six got my iPads on for
breakfast we are doing a totally health
food packed mini okay no he's joking
now on the final day of this week we had
an event my really good friend son was
turning three and she's having a big
backyard birthday party for him there is
nothing more tempting sugar wives than a
birthday party so we're all the way to
the birthday party we have two arguing
kits in the back so I'm a little nervous
because they're already in kind of
gnarly moods and they have it yep today
how do you think we're gonna do at this
birthday party with no sugar oh yeah to
be continued on that so far so good
there's a bounce house there is so so
far so good at the end of the party we
were doing so well we're packing up our
stuff to go and I made the fatal mistake
of peeing you parents out there no you
can never go to the bathroom without
something horrible happening
would you take a cupcake out of your
very temperamental three-year-olds hands
at a party with a bunch of other parents
yeah no I was not about to go there but
then when why it has the cupcake in his
hands that's not fair to Jackson so
Jackson needs a cupcake and it just
triggered this chain of events of like
ah you get a cupcake and you get a
cupcake and I had to literally like yell
at Matt to back away from the cake about
it drop the knife
walk away walk away stop the cupcake
cycle like stop everybody stop and
here's the kicker of the whole cupcake
situation while I was in the bathroom
Matt was outside with the kids
no not accusing him giving Wyatt the
cupcake himself but all I know is that
he assisted in unwrapping it so in total
we made it six and three-quarters of the
day which is six days longer than I
really thought we would last good enough
so in conclusion my learnings from this
week one of the main reasons why I did
this experiment is because I was looking
to see how it would affect my kids I was
looking at their temperament their
behavior and their sleeping habits and I
definitely saw improvement in all three
they really did seem to have an improved
mood and more energy and just not
crashing so much at the end of the day
now for me I kind of had the opposite
effect I was so aware that we weren't
eating any sugar it just made me think
about it all the time and so I felt very
distracted throughout the week Oh Mona
happy I love kale I love grass I kind of
envy my kids because they were for the
most part oblivious to this experiment
because they have someone just making
food for them I kind of wish I had this
magic food maker who just decided
everything I got to eat instead of me
just eating a bunch of cottage cheese
all week so going forward I really think
that there are a lot of swaps that we
can do and a lot of things we can be
more conscious of stead of cereal
serving oatmeal
or instead of packaged fruit bars we'll
just eat fresh fruit I think those are
little swaps and little changes that are
gonna help us long term and I'm
definitely gonna be more mindful
shopping in the grocery store to look at
the ingredients and really look for what
I'm bringing into our house because oh
that has frickin sugar all of it oh
that's all I got for today I'm Hanna and
if you have any tips or tricks to get
your kids to eat better please leave
them in the comments but be nice to each
other guys because we're all just trying
to get by here or you can text me this
is a real number and I do read each and
every one I don't always respond because
I get a lot but I love hearing what you
guys have to say but if you'll please
excuse me my kids are asleep this is my
time sit on the couch like the slots
that I am and enjoy a box of Girl Scout
cookies til next time
[Music]
and I'm it will
[Music]
don't look at me